we've so far leaving two main things
that are really good for us in solving
these kinds of equations okay the two
main things have been does anyone
remember what the two meetings are first
we expand okay so yeah you see all these
brackets should I get rid of the
brackets okay and then we collect like
terms that was a second thing excellent
okay now when you look at this we are
going to do both of these things but
they've added an extra layer of
complexity that's why the head is more
complex equations which means that
before we get to these we've got to do
something else okay what's the
difference what extra thing is they
added pressures right now they put this
to you if I could somehow get rid of
these fractions that I'll be back into a
situation where I can do these and I've
heard okay so how do I get rid of
fractions well I'm gonna need to do some
multiplication because a fraction is
about division right so to get rid of
them I'm gonna multiply by something
yeah okay now I am gonna multiply by 6
I'm gonna multiply this side by 6 which
means I better do the other side
but a question which you need to ask is
why 6 yeah I will expand it but first
I'm going to do the over you'll see why
in a second why 6 it has to do with
these two doubles okay so number one you
might have noticed Oh 2 times 3 is 6
that's cool but more specifically it is
important idea it's the lowest common
multiple
okay no no multiple factors different
got the highest common factor which is
so this is an important idea it's sold
what you need to write it down okay two
and three I want to get rid of both of
them in one fell swoop okay the way you
do it is you multiply both sides by the
lowest color multiple up two and three
okay so watch what happens let's do this
if I do this over here okay do you agree
with me just so we put the same other
side here that 3x plus 1 right that's
the society over 2 that's the same as 3
over 2 X plus 1 is that okay I've done
the division over here but it's the same
thing I'm still dividing it by truth
okay so therefore I'm gonna write it
like that it's gonna make it a little
simpler for me as you'll see in a second
okay so what I've gotten is that 3 over
2 X plus 1 there that's just that's okay
I'll go do the same thing here so I'm
gonna get 5 over 3x plus 1 okay but but
I've multiplied everything by 6
everything by 6
okay so I multiply this by 6 is 1 and
then I multiply this by 6 okay no stop
make sure you know what's going on okay
this is just like this situation
okay you know when you do we expand me
brackets it looks really hard because
there's always awkward numbers there but
you guys don't have to do this this is
just no more expense this is 6a plus the
six billion all right you got to do 6
times moment it's not 12 maybe because
the A's are the big so there's my 6a at
the front there's my 6b
okay so all I've done is expand over
that side okay before I deal with that
we should deal with my head side as well
four times six just a second four times
easy okay question I will shortly yeah
yeah I will but I've got these different
denominators which is a problem I'll fix
it up watch see here's what I'm gonna do
okay can you see that 6 times 2 there's
gonna be some canceling happening over
here right some cancelling what's gonna
cancel what's what so I'm going to
divide through both of these by can I
divide through by 6 divided by 2 is that
okay so I'm gonna get 3 times 3 which is
9 okay right what happened is I became I
can cancel again seeks in the 3 I can
can't side a factor of 3
that's two okay Jimmy slide down ten
records two times five that's ten okay
then cut yeah that's right I did two
things at once I cancelled and I'd
multiply it okay wait
yep what's up Internet these guys these
guys time stay cool now at this point
this is interesting okay
and this is what Ollie was talking about
just down usually we expand and we click
like test and we usually do it in that
order
but this time I don't actually need to
expand just yet watch can you see I've
got X plus ones here right and I've got
Xbox ones here so if you see that so
I've got those those are like terms
visit terms that are like we used to see
a little bit like like a plus 10k right
but doesn't matter it can be anything
you like these two x plus ones right
they're both like terms I've got nine
here and I've got ten here so when you
got night or something and 10 of
something you put the other you get 19
19 mots off the Y term namely it's what
it's not all right yeah
okay cool this is really good because at
this point right I can get rid of my
teeth straight away I can divide them
over the other side right so if I divide
this side by 19 I'll divide this side by
19 as well dad okay divide both sides
okay I get X plus 1 over here okay no
one I should take away one from both
sides
okay now written down one there but we
could write in a more helpful way I've
got to subtract it from 19th that's a
bit of awkward isn't it
how many 19 are there in one there are
19 19 right so I'm gonna write that is
19 19 okay and to 24 minus 19 is 5 now
if you want I can show you all the ways
of doing it like there's lots of
different paths down here it's just like
if you're going from you're going from
cherrybrook to you know the city there's
at least like 10 different ways major
roads you can take but they'll all get
you the same place in here is funny yeah
yeah sure I went through quite quickly
what I had here how do I get from this
line to this line what I do remember I
subtracted 1 from both sides so really
there's a minus 1 there but I noticed
that I mean when do I have fractions
together I want them on the same
denominator right I want 19th in other
words so that's why I said well 1 is the
same as the 18 over 19 that's where he
came for all that